let's give ourselves a reminder of how
important Gregor Mendel's work was in
1866 that he published in 1866 and it's
important to realize it wasn't like
immediately in 1866 or 1867 the whole
world changed and everyone said Oh
Gregor Mendel figured it all out like a
lot of times in science the big
discoveries the ones that really change
people think it change people's
thinking's aren't really taken that
seriously at first and actually Mendel's
work a lot of people either didn't take
it seriously or kind of ignored it in
1866 and it wasn't until the early
1900's that people rediscovered his work
and realized wait wait there's something
very very powerful here and we might be
able to connect it to things that we are
actually observing inside of cells but
let's just remind ourselves about
Mendel's work so for most of human
history we've recognized probably that
okay looks like the animals and we're
not just animals
any type of living creature seems to
pass on traits to their offspring I
could look at you and I'd say well you
know your hair is kind of like your
dad's and your eyes are kinda like your
mom's maybe your nose looks like
something in between you walk a little
bit like your uncle so it we've always
recognized that that we pass on traits
to our offspring but we didn't really
have a rigorous way of thinking about it
and we definitely didn't have any way to
make predictions that were testable
based on those traits and that's what
Mendel gave us
he said well look I'm observing and he
did this with pea plants I observed
these heritable factors and there might
be heritable factors on let's say height
if we're talking about plants it would
be the height of a plant there might be
heritable factors on let's say flour
color so flour flour color and you
recognize that there are different
versions of those factors and so a given
plant might have one of the tall
versions so they might have a tall
version for the height factor and they
might have a short version or they might
have two tall's
or they might have two shorts or they
might have a red factor and they have a
pink factor or they could have two Reds
two Reds
it would look like that or two pinks
would look like that but the important
realization was that there was these
there was these versions of the factor
today we call these factors you say hey
there's a gene for height if there is
one or that there is a gene for flower
colors and those variations of the genes
today we call these alleles so we'd say
you have the variation you have one copy
of the tall allele and one copy of the
short let me just write it this way let
me just say these are all these are all
alleles right here so you have one tall
one short allele and what Mendel did is
he realized well look these things are
the art we didn't know how but these
things are the things that get passed on
from one and from-from a parent to their
offspring and he started described about
how they got passed on he observed that
even if you have two of these that they
tend to segregate when you go to the
next generation and what we what do we
mean by segregation or I guess we could
say the law of segregation law of
segregation well that means if this was
if I'm a pea plant and these are these
are the versions that I have to my
offspring I might pass on an a a capital
A the tall one or I could pass on the
lowercase a I might pass on the tall or
I might pass on the red version of the
flower color factor or I might pass on
or I might pass on the pink one and he
also realized that whether or not I pass
on the capital A or the lowercase a it's
independent of whether I pass on the
capital B or the lowercase B so they
independently assort how this one of
sorts is independent of how this one of
sorts so independent assortment in the
pendent independent assortment
assortment law law of independent
assortment and he also observed that
some of these versions
the other one so if an offspring has a
tall version and a short one if the tall
one is dominant the the observed trait
will still look tall and that the only
way they look short is if they have two
versions of the short one and so that
one he described as his law of dominance
law of dominance and if all of this is
completely new to you I encourage you to
watch watch the videos on Mendelian
genetics on Khan Academy but this is
just going to appreciation a little bit
of a historical appreciation but as big
as Handel has as big of a deal as
Mendel's work was it's also important to
realize what he didn't know he had no
idea of how this was actually happening
at a molecular level or at a cellular
level and it wasn't until the early
1900s that people started to have fairly
robust theories of how this happens and
so in 1902 and 1903 so 1902 1903 these
two gentlemen independently start coming
up with the chromosome theory of
inheritance and it's called the very
Sutton chromosome theory of inheritance
cuz right around the same time they both
started to realize that maybe
chromosomes were the actual molecular
mechanism the cellular mechanism by
which these factors segregate and
independently assort and so this is let
me write this down this is the bow very
well very sutton and sometimes called
the sutton bow very but very sutton
chromosome theory chromosome theory and
even even though they're starting to say
maybe chromosomes have something to do
with it they still don't know exactly
what is inside the chromosomes that are
allowing the somehow this information to
be encoded and we'll get to that and we
will get to that in a little bit but let
me just underline this beware the very
Sutton chromosome theory and so what was
their key insight well they started a
look inside of cells meiosis was
observed actually after Mendel published
his his laws of inheritance and then
chromosomes or
how chromosomes behave in meiosis were
discovered after that and then these
guys they independently studied
different organisms
Walter Sutton he studied grasshoppers
Theodor Boveri he studied sea urchins
but they looked at meiosis and they
looked at the reproduction and the
fertilization during these processes and
they saw that the chromosomes seemed to
do things that were very similar to
these laws of segregation laws of
independent assortment laws of dominance
and actually the law of dominance we'll
talk more about in future videos but he
saw that let's say that you had a an
organism here and in this a particular
organism I just did it for
simplification it has two pairs of
homologous chromosomes so what does
homologous chromosomes mean well these
these two are different chromosomes but
they seem to be very similar it seems
like they're kind of the same length
same size same shape so that's one pair
of homologous chromosomes
that's another pair of homologous
chromosomes so notice homologous
chromosomes two things that are kind of
looking the same but maybe they're
they're a little bit different we're not
sure well maybe maybe this is this is
this is this is what fits what's going
on right over here with these factors
maybe just maybe maybe one of these
chromosomes somehow has on at some place
what encodes for the capital a capital A
and maybe the other chromosome in a in
the similar part of the chromosome in a
similar part of the chromosome has what
encodes a similar part of the chromosome
has what encodes for a lowercase a now
this this is starting to make sense
because they would be homologous
chromosomes similar they're those
chromosomes look like they code for the
same thing for the same factors for the
same genes but there might be some
variation between these chromosomes and
these guys weren't you know they weren't
able to somehow sequence the the
chromosomes so they didn't know they
don't even know that the the DNA was
what was important in the chromosomes
but they said well it looks like these
two things as we look through the
process of meiosis it seems like they
segregate from each other for example
this capital A one it'll replicate so
you have capital A but then and then the
the lowercase a one right over here you
might have some crossover and we'll talk
about that when you you could review
meiosis if if that looks unfamiliar but
then they segregate you could have your
capital a ones right over here and then
these sister chromatids split apart so
capital a capital A and then you have
lowercase a these lowercase a ones they
segregate and they independently assort
from the other chromosomes so this one
right over here might be the capital B
this might be the lowercase B and
whether or not this gets a whether or
not this gets a capital B or a lowercase
B is independent of whether it got a
capital A or a lowercase a so it seems
like these chromosomes independently
assort and so they came up with this
chromosomal theory that it looks like
maybe chromosomes are what contain these
heritable factors that Mendel was
talking about because it seems like
chromosomes behaved very similar to
those heritable factors maybe
chromosomes code for multiple of these
heritable factors that segregate and
independently assort and as we know now
they were right so this was a very very
big deal but it's important to realize
that they weren't sure they established
the theory they were able to make some
of observations with the grasshoppers
and the sea urchins and they saw the
patterns between what Mendel was
describing in the way chromosomes
behaved during meiosis and then they
know that each of these each of these
products of meiosis each of these each
of these gametes will then go and form
with other gametes to form the next
organism so you say look parents will
contribute either a capital A or a
lowercase a either a capital B or a
lowercase B so it says this is very
similar to what Mendel was describing so
they laid the foundry but they still
weren't sure they didn't definitively
prove it and we'll take a few more
another decade or so until it's
definitively proven and even then no one
was really sure exactly how these
different traits were encoded and for
that we would have to wait a little bit
longer